what's the dog responsible for 95% of
all bites pites are just genetic
breeding for a long time the Roman
Empire they'd rais dogs they'd look at
the litter of puppies the meanest one
they'd keep theyd kill all the rest they
did that hundreds and hundreds of times
the mean Dad bred them over and over
most border colly dogs which is the
highest IQ dog they're all related to a
one dog from the 1800s his name is
Wiston cap every Pro dog trainer would
fly their females to breed with Wiston
and what dog has the highest IQ Border
Collies it's Border Collies then poodles
what do you say to the people that have
pit bulls and they say no this is
friendly dog would never hurt a soul
people lie but numbers don't and still
95% of dog bites are like two breeds
isn't it pitel and Chihuahuas chihuaha
attacks all things it's like all thing
it's just their mouth's not big enough
to break the skin